[Music]
so gavin newsom
is the governor of our largest state
california he's a liberal democrat but
the problem is deeper than that it's not
even ideological he's just a bad
governor the state doesn't work very
well it's more crowded every year it's
dirty as hell he got junkies living on
every street corner in every park and
they can't even keep the power on
so it's a failed state it's embarrassing
and even if you don't live in california
you should be embarrassed and horrified
by it why do we allow this and why
let some tiny brained [ __ ] like gavin
newsom
wreck our prettiest state that's how
most people in the state feel even the
democrats so they're going to recall him
a lot of people joined the race and last
week one of our friends did larry elder
who's a radio show host in the state
joined in the recall effort and the
election to replace him
but now the state of california is
trying to keep larry elder off the
ballot
so today elder announced he is suing the
california secretary of state
shirley weber from for wrongfully
blocking him
from the ballot talk about an attack on
democracy
he says he's complied with the state
laws and the move to block him is
entirely political which
since it's california you can believe
larry elder joins us tonight larry
thanks so much for coming on
congratulations on your run unlike a lot
of people who run for office you've been
very clear about what you believe it's
all on the record no one needs to guess
about what you would do because you've
got decades of saying it out loud
tell us how they're trying to keep you
off the ballot
well tucker we have gone to court we
filed a lawsuit last night
we're probably going to have a hearing
tomorrow and not only me there's also a
woman named betty chu
who's the first chinese american to pass
the bar in california she's in her 80s
she still ticked off
she filed the lawsuit for herself and
she said she's doing it for other people
who are now being deprived of the
opportunity to vote for larry elder
because the secretary of state has
denied me the opportunity to be on the
ballot
and what they're arguing tucker is out
of the 300 pages of five years of tax
returns that we
turned in i didn't redact something that
should have been redacted
or redacted something that shouldn't
have been redacted i'm not quite sure
which it is
all i know is that there's a provision
that allows the secretary of state to
correct any minor discrepancy and she
elected not to do it
and that is why i believe that i was
targeted now a lot of people have asked
me tucker
was this racism now you know me for a
long time i don't play that
and what i said is it's not racism it's
facism it's larry elder because they
know that i'm the guy
who can take this guy down as you
pointed out i've been talking about
these issues
for some 30 years i'm on in every major
market in in california i have higher
name recognition
than any of the other candidates other
than caitlyn jenner
uh people know me i'm from the hood i'm
from the inner city i can talk
firsthand about the declining quality of
schools i can talk firsthand about why
we have
rising crime why we have rising
homelessness why the cost of living has
gotten so outrageous that for the first
time
in our state's history people are
leaving california and going to places
like texas
and tennessee and florida it is
outrageous there's a magazine called ceo
magazine
been around for 17 years tucker and for
17 years
california has been determined to be the
worst state in which to do business
of all 50 states and i can turn that
around and they are scared to death
i mean if people are moving from san
francisco which has got to be the
prettiest city we have in this entire
country and moving to reno
which no offense is not and if a lot of
people are doing that it really tells
you
that it's like so mismanaged that you're
seeing an exodus of normal people i mean
can you can you win the battle to be
on the ballot i mean they say they they
care about democracy but they're trying
to keep you off the ballot like how does
that work even
no no i'm going to be on the ballot
we're going to prevail in the lawsuit
and if we don't we'll take it up to the
california supreme court
this law was designed to make donald
trump turn over five years of tax
returns in order to be eligible
uh to run for re-election in california
in 2020. it was litigated all the way up
to the left-wing california supreme
court
and they voted unanimously 7-0 that the
law was unconstitutional both california
constitution
and the u.s constitution but they did
say it was okay for gubernatorial races
it's not even clear it applies to a
recall election that's why i'm telling
people to go to
elector.com elect elder.com throw a
little something in the tip jar because
he has unlimited ability to raise money
and spend money his rivals on the other
hand
have campaign finance limits and
regarding public education
there are three hundred thousand public
school teachers here in california
tucker i'm told
by expert after expert at least five
percent are incompetent
that's 15 000 teachers that are walking
the halls of our schools
miseducating our kids i want choice in
school as do urban
parents black and brown yet they pull
the lever for the party that denies it
and i'm going to turn that around
and and there's only about
75 percent of black kids in california
tucker cannot read at state levels of
proficiency
my former high school crenshaw high
school the one that was featured in the
movie boys in the hood
two percent of the kids are math
proficient it is outrageous
yeah and they're the ones lecturing
racism by the way you have to show your
tax returns to run for office why not a
literacy test or a poll tax i mean what
the hell
speaking of a barrier to entry and
democracy like wow that's hard to
believe that's even real
and i hope you beat it hope you spank it
larry elder thank you
we'll be following carefully my pleasure
elect elder.com amen hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else